Buenas tardes el Primer Ministro Alberto
tarola va a exponer ante el parlamento
el plan de gobierno de la presidenta
Dina boluarte que se basa en tres ejes
fundamentales educación lucha contra la
corrupción y destrabe de proyectos Pero
lo que más espera Es que este nuevo
gobierno genere confianza en la
población y justamente las protestas que
se han producido en las últimas horas en
el sur de Perú que han generado 18
muertos va a influir en el voto que den
los congresistas esta tarde noche luego
del debate que se forme tras el informe
del Primer Ministro este gabinete
requiere 66 votos del parlamento peruano
para obtener la confianza bueno y
Hablamos ahora del paro porque la
jornada de ayer fue una de las más
violentas qué repercusiones se han
presentado porque ya sabemos que hay una
denuncia penal contra El Ejecutivo por
las muertes y por los heridos durante
las manifestaciones
precisamente la congresista Ruth Luque
acaba de denunciar penalmente ante la
fiscalía a la presidenta Dina boluarte
al Primer Ministro Alberto otarola y
otros ministros por las más de cuarenta
muertes y más de trescientos heridos que
se han registrado en todos estos días de
protesta al respecto el gobierno
Regional de puno ha declarado tres días
de duelo por la muerte de 17 civiles
durante estos enfrentamientos por su
parte la policía peruana ha denunciado
que un suboficial murió calcinado luego
que una turba agredía a una patrulla el
Primer Ministro Alberto tarot la
responsabilizado de toda esta aula de
violencia al expresidente Pedro casi